are you still playing rocket League well
I definitely am and it sounds like we'll
be playing it for quite a while two is
developed for psyonix has no plans to
make a sequel anytime soon
I'm Matt this is a GameSpot news update
and make sure to LIKE and subscribe stay
up to date on all of the new rocket
League modes and features bionix VP
geremy Dunham appeared on kind of funny
games and said why would we want to take
this huge community that we've already
built that's still growing and say what
you're playing now is going to be
irrelevant in twelve months but we want
you to stop what you're doing give us
money all over again
and move over to this other game that's
not the right way to do things
he added that Sonic's will continue
adding new content as long as its
community continues to play it he even
said that the developer is thinking of
new features that are still one or two
years away from released so it seems
safe to expect ongoing support for
awhile to come rocket League is
currently available on ps4 Xbox one and
PC there haven't been any announcements
of a version for the Nintendo switch but
we'll keep you updated as NORs revealed
and if you want more awesome sports
action check out our video on extreme
sports presip a wild style
[Music]
[Music]